bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors ce
gouvernement l'exécutif aussi qu'ils ont
martelé aux français la nécessité de se
faire vacciner
ils sont maintenant forcés de suspendre
la vaccination avec le produit anglo
suédois
c'est vrai que l'exécutif marche sur des
oeufs comment est-ce que vous jugez sa
communication
c'est une communication qui s'est
effectué un peu dans la précipitation et
qui finalement montre l'image d'un pays
qui a intériorisé d'une certaine manière
la domination de l'allemagne parce que
on peut se poser la question de savoir
si les allemands eux mêmes n'avaient pas
pris cette décision si la france se
serait aligné sur une décision similaire
donc ça c'est le plat le premier le
premier enseignement que l'on peut tirer
de cette séquence de communication le
deuxième enseignement c'est que et c'est
plus une question en l'occurrence c'est
de savoir dans un pays où finalement on
avait quand même réussi à rattraper un
peu le retard en terme de confiance
vis-à-vis de la vaccination ces
dernières semaines est-ce que l'annoncé
hier par le président de la république
ne va pas disons réactiver la défiance
dans le vaccin et plus largement dans la
stratégie de vaccination que l'exécutif
souhaite mettre en place pour maintenant
sortir de cette crise sanitaire parce
qu'on a bien compris que de toute façon
il n'y avait pas d'autre solution pour
finalement faire en sorte que la société
puisse revivre normalement que celle
d'avoir une vaccination qu'ils puissent
se déployer de manière rapide
on apprend juste à l'instant emmanuel
macron qui devrait s'entretenir cet
après midi avec des membres du conseil
scientifique probablement à 17 heures
selon nos confrères de bfm tv il ya ce
principe de précaution qui justifie
selon justement les autorités la
suspension de la vaccination avec
astrazeneca est ce que il n'ya pas quand
même une prudence qui
nsfr dans ce cas précis dans cette
affaire écoutez moi je suis pas
scientifique donc je n'ai pas d'éléments
venir qui me permette à l'état d'aller
dans un sens ou dans l'autre en
l'occurrence ce qui est quand même clair
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on voit que royaume
uni on vaccine massivement qu'il y a a
si peu d'effets secondaires roi que en
israël la société redémarre parce que on
a pu déployer une stratégie de
vaccination très efficace et organisé de
manière très rigoureuse
alors ensuite en effet aujourd'hui il y
a des opinions publiques qui sont
extrêmement sensibles plus que par le
passé à toute la question des
conséquences des évolutions techniques
et technologiques et c'est la raison
pour laquelle d'ailleurs on a
constitutionnalisé en france le principe
de précaution mais force est de
constater aussi que la situation
sanitaire aujourd'hui par les blocages
qu'elle suscite dans le fonctionnement
de la société induit d'autres risques
qui sont des l'isq psychologique les
risques sociaux des risques salutaire et
il faut bien mesurer à travers j'allais
dire des paramètres de bénéfices et des
risques
ce que le retard que l'on prend dans la
stratégie de vaccination s'il devait se
prolonger nous allons voir dans les
heures qui viennent ce que ce retard
impliquerait aussi sur le fonctionnement
de la société et sur l'issue que l'on
peut éventuellement autre voie en
matière de sortie de crise par justement
vous évoquez le cas britannique à bord
et johnson qui réaffirme donc hors que
ça fonctionne bien
sur le territoire britannique cette
vaccination avec astrazeneca l'annoncent
d' emmanuel macron elle est intervenue
lundi et cette annonce a est venu
contredire les propos de son premier
ministre la veille qui a fermé toute sa
confiance en ce vaccin est ce qu'il faut
voir peut-être une divergence de
stratégie au plus haut niveau de l'état
à tenir justement dans cette affaire je
suis bien sûr qu'il ya une divergence
sur ce sujet là c'est que l'exécutif à
lui certainement des éléments
d'information qui ont précipité la
communication des manuels macro ce lundi
par rapport aux propos qu'il a pu tenir
le premier ministre la veille lors de
son intervention sur le réseau twitter
je pense qu'il ya une divergence son
essai au sein de l'exécutif n'était pas
lié tellement liés à la stratégie de
vaccination qui est plutôt lié au niveau
de contraintes sanitaires qu'il faut
faire peser sur la société française
aujourd'hui afin de pouvoir lutter
contre le virus on sait qu'il existe un
parti qui doit partie médicale en
l'occurrence qui considère qu'il faut
relever le niveau des contraintes
sanitaires vont être confiné tout ou
partie du territoire c'est la ligne qui
est plutôt défendu en l'occurrence par
le ministre de la santé via aussi le
conseil scientifique et puis une ligne
qui est une ligne j'allais dire plus
économique qui est défendu manifestement
pas entre autres bruno le maire mais
aussi le président de la république il
considère qu' il faut bien être
aujourd'hui à la société de vivre avec
le virus et de le part confiné je pense
que s'il ya aujourd'hui des lignes de
divergences au sein de l'exécutif elles
sont plutôt sur ce sujet là que sur la
question de la vaccination mais n'est
mâcon qui doit s'exprimer normalement
dans quelques jours ce sera donc après
leur baisse qui se réunit aujourd'hui
l'agencé européenne du médicament
je dis ça va quand même être compliqué
de reprendre la main auprès l'opinion
publique
oui c'est très compliqué parce que si
vous voulez aujourd'hui le la france
dans la gestion de cette crise très
mon passif depuis le début de l'épidémie
est bon on va pas revenir sur la
polémique et les controverses autour des
masques sur les contres reste retour des
lits d'hôpitaux
tout se passe comme si finalement on se
retrouvait aujourd'hui à la mi mars un
an en arrière en l'occurrence et on ne
voit pas véritablement les leçons ou les
vautours d'expérience qui ont été tirées
des dysfonctionnements ce que nous avons
pu connaître d'autant plus que les
paluds attaqueront a fait un choix qui
est le choix justement d'élite et de re
confiné l'ensemble du pays et qu' il
veut absolument obtenir cette lilas pour
aussi faire la démonstration que
l'option qui l'a retenu est d été de la
bonne sauf que en effet aujourd'hui le
problème qui se pose sur les vaccins
l'area si brutale de la campagne de
vaccination en tout cas en ce qui
concerne le vaccin
astrazeneca vient profondément
handicapée
l'option qui l'a retenu parce que on
revient que l'option qui était en fait
d'éviter leur confinement
elle était aussi indexé sur le fait
qu'on puisse aller très rapidement dans
la campagne de vaccination merci
beaucoup à vous à arnaud des métiers je
le rappelle on vient de l'apprendre
emmanuel macron qui devrait s'entretenir
à 17 heures avec les membres du conseil
scientifique et une seconde réunion est
prévue entre lui et des réanimateurs
cette fois à 18 heures merci beaucoup à
vous faire